the delivery truck is almost empty
for weeks almost no wares have been
arriving from egypt
wholesaler honey altalawi can fill only
a fraction of his orders
normally he supplies vegetables
beverages and canned goods to this cafe
an important meeting place for egyptians
in stuttgart
the unrest in their home country is the
topic of conversation
shrapnel injured his brother and he's
worried about him
everyone who loves egypt must take a
democratic path
the people have to learn to listen to
each other and not destroy the country
has one of the stuttgart area's largest
firms specializing in delicacies from
the arab world
without the imports from egypt he'll
lose half his business
maybe i should call up the company now
to order
we have to order
since nothing is arriving from egypt has
to import goods from other countries
for example beans from lebanon
and other products from morocco or
jordan
we import about 40 of our wares from
egypt
and the rest from other arab countries
if the situation remains unstable our
company will lose money
because we can't sell what we don't
import
it currently takes up to eight weeks for
commodities from egypt to arrive in
germany
many of the wholesalers suppliers have
ceased production
they aren't getting the needed raw
materials and their employees aren't
showing up for work
talawi has lived in germany for 30 years
he's worried about his family in egypt
and i must be assassin my sister my
mother and all kinds of other relatives
live there
for the first time they're afraid to go
out on the street
that's new for egypt that people are
simply shot dead
the egyptian wholesaler supplies
supermarkets and restaurants all over
southern germany and in switzerland
he hopes the situation normalizes soon
ibrahim samak is also watching the
events closely
he's the head of an engineering firm in
stuttgart ingotech
that builds solar energy facilities it
put the roof on the reichstag in berlin
and he wants to expand solar energy in
egypt too
we have just completed a major project
in egypt
it's a solar collecting system on an
office building in cairo
and it produces 140 kilowatts
now we're waiting for new contracts but
at the moment nothing is happening
egypt wants to develop renewable
energies but as long as there's no
political security
many projects will find no investors
when the situation in egypt stabilizes
again
and the economic situation begins to
improve
there will be more commissions in the
solar market
and more work for us
hani ao talawi heads back to the cafe in
downtown stuttgart
he's meeting with other arab
entrepreneurs
they've set up a bank account for aid
donations for egypt
to be collected all over germany